[Music]
uh let's see here so we we have
something fun just to start off with uh
alex jones
uh you know we were playing the video of
him as a young kid that's been circling
the internet
uh well
he knows people have been talking about
it he knows we're talking by the way he
knows we talked about it and uh here's
what he has to say
and so yeah i don't look like i used to
i could look a lot better i've got a
family that looks great at 60 70 years
old but i took on all the stress i stood
up and and i stayed up
with nothing but coffee
probably two nights a week for the first
four or five years i was on air i worked
20 hours a day i hand edited all the
films i i went and had jobs on top of it
i did the sales jobs the radio stations
and had my all of it taken away from me
i didn't care because i cared about the
mission and so do i look like a war
hardened goblin damn right i do and out
of it because i'm not trying to win
pretty boy contest around here i'm here
to take on the pain and take on the
attacks and dedicate myself to bringing
down the new world order because i will
not spiritually and i will not
genetically sign on to what satan's
doing so all you people like brad pitt
and and and
another little globalist that sells he
named him one actor
all your other people like brad pitt and
and also it's even like a current one
yeah like is brad pitt a current
reference at this point oh nice
breitling
oh well you know
uh uncle alex still got a couple bucks
yeah leather oh the leather one nice
another little globalist excelsior
over there i mean i mean there's so many
of them leonardo's
should we invite alex to a pool one day
and see if it fogs up that's the only
way to know
how about i have an idea
harrison i know you're not listening so
listen here's what i'm thinking
alex jones
pickup artist
i like it think about that he walks up
to women and screams in their face about
civilians while we're addressing uh
harrison uh i should make a
recommendation we want to know if his
watches are real so harrison just listen
to us this will be good for your career
steal one of alex's watches see what
happens and give it to us thank you yeah
but don't worry it's not what you think
we're gonna sell it for money
yeah if he wants it he can go to go to
west coast gun and pawn and [ __ ]
balkan that's the only way he can get
him there yeah
of course it'll be enraging he'll go
there to buy it back and they'll be like
yeah this uh mike shealy pawned this and
honestly for a freakishly low amount i
mean we you know we even tried to tell
him he could get more than 500 for this
that's all he that's all we gave him
uh over there i mean i mean there's so
many of them leonardo dicaprio you just
rub skin creams on your faces all day
and try to stay young because when you
die your soul and your energy is going
to be sunken to the middle of a black
hole with all the energy just like you
because like attracts like but as for me
i don't care about this body i just want
it to last long enough to carry out my
mission to bring down the new world
order and i know all of you agree with
me in this quest
so we're going to do it ladies and
gentlemen when he says
i really picture him as like an npc
giving you a quest in it
i'd give anything like you know if we
didn't live in this world where
everybody was just getting de-platformed
over [ __ ] we could we could have
that silliness we would have alex jones
cameos in like an elder scrolls game
i don't care what you do you got to get
the goddamn thalmor and also alex
they're out here and they're trying to
take over the government like just going
off about thal more elves
alex and also do me a favor buddy don't
talk down about yourself you're an
absolute unit what are you talking about
you're a tank class
i just i want i just want alex giving me
missions and elder scrolls
that would be good
oh you got these goddamn the high elves
they're hanging down there and somerset
ew i'm going to rule over you not on my
watch
pounding a desk at an inn
and you're like dude i just need to buy
potions
and he sells potions too which would be
great
he sells all kind he has an alchemy
store he just sells like uh super male
vitality yes
i got some uh i got some skooma in the
back if you're looking for that too
and that's why they're hiding the elder
scrolls they're hiding them from us
oh man [ __ ]
i love me some alex man yeah that's
that's one of those like
if something ever happens to him that'll
be on a patrice level
where i have to legit take the day off
you know i used to be an info warrior
like you until twitter put an arrow in
my knee
not even a legitimate emperor he's not
part of the dragon bloodline
can you ima okay now i'm imagining going
after all the yarls and calling him
satanists
you know folks i want to tell you a
little something about uh you know why i
don't go to windhelm anymore uh-oh
i used to love windham i used to go
there hunt boar
and hang out with the yarrow
but you want to start a civil war
going off about how going off about all
for stormcloaks actually a fed
i think he's working for the teth elmore
oh man getting mad about the cajet
invasion
[Laughter]
he's like i got the documents and you're
like yeah i know i do too i did the
thalmor mission i didn't read all the
books i know
he's sitting he's sitting at the tavern
with a bunch of scrolls in front of him
like he has on his desk just a bunch of
scrolls and
you're right this ella goes old
paperwork
and of course harrison smith would be
leader of the blades yeah of course he
won
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that was everything else
everything harrison does is all cloak
and dagger it's just little letters that
you get
meet me at the tavern at 8 p.m
they just
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
somebody's asking if somebody could make
this mod that would be fine alex jones
mod would be amazing
[Music]
like you because you could do it but
make it not you know what though it's
funny we could probably
if we could get somebody to make the mod
i know i know some people that know how
to make those mods
i'm sure we could get alex to record
dialogue
kyle goes the elites are sacrificing for
the daedra i'm not saying that they
believe that
[Laughter]
i'm telling you man
we could probably get alex to do a
little bit of dialogue for us
and then just have somebody make the mod
oh [ __ ] a bunch of danger worship and
pedophiles
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
they had a they tried they tried me team
up with a nick like a vampire i wouldn't
do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
folks you got to be careful he's on he's
on the air like ivermectin but he's
drinking the cure potion to stop the
vampirism yeah
within three days folks
he's just drinking it
you're walking you're walking in this
infowars tavern he's like you look sick
you should get some sun
yeah okay fine so i don't look as good
as i used to back in the day but that's
cause i got rock joint as i got clipped
on by a mud crab
and i forgot to drink my potions
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
now you got me love running around here
like like some like some bosmer [ __ ] on
on a payday so juice almighty goes them
reptilian argonian shaped shape-shifting
wolves
and look folks the empire is going to
keep fighting their wars
all over
it's never going to end
[Laughter]
what are we doing out there in morrowind
anyway i mean we got no business there
folks they're a different culture
you ever asked yourself you ever asked
yourself why there's no babies here in
skyrim
think about it
and we're down there bombing kids in the
black marsh
what have we got to do with them lizard
people nothing
shouldn't be fighting any wars against
the lizard people
oh [ __ ]
jesus christ and then he's like alex has
super male vitality if you have coin
paul allen goes they're taking the
freaking argonians gay
can we make owen a gadget that'd be
great owen schroeder gets to be a gadget
this one is still sitting in a prison
this one is still getting no due process
he has the same facial hair that would
actually be really funny that's why he's
a casual it's perfect the same facial
hair
this one is only hoping to perhaps get
the bond
malevolent bystander goes i guess only
nerds get these jokes yeah
yeah [ __ ] you you should be a nerd it's
[ __ ] rude
awesome
yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah
jim edward goes this one these are
federal agents
oh [ __ ]
oh that's good [ __ ] [ __ ] man
now let me tell you about super red
guard vitality
[Music]
oh [ __ ] man
yeah all right i've heard people saying
i'm on skooma
i don't use skooma damn it all right i
just like a good nord ale like any other
man
he gets starts screaming rips his armor
off
[Laughter]
oh man somebody's going to have to put a
adonis paul to work on this that's a
good well i already had he said he was
gonna do two other ones that he hasn't
done so good luck
um
dragon and they wonder why all the
volcanoes are erupting to morrowind
method taxes and don't forget folks
right now we have a sale on dragon bone
broth
dragon boat broth
and then and then he just literally just
goes to the imperial city and lights the
dragon fires by himself yes like he's
not even of the right bloodline he just
goes ah
and all they all light up and they're
like i guess he's the new emperor
oh god he does this walk up the mountain
he just pushes the troll away and keeps
walking yeah
no no somebody has to animate the you
know the uh you know that video that
they've used a hundred times of him
chasing the guy oh yes yes nobody needs
to take that video go get back here you
son of a [ __ ] as though as the frost
troll jumps off the hill and runs
[Laughter]
you're a liar you're a deceiver get back
here you son of a [ __ ] this is running
after death club oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
man now that's all i want in my life
[Music]
anyway
uh there are s i haven't found any
videos there are like some of these
that you can find but there's not any
there yeah but there there is uh there's
the one where he goes through the
oblivion gate which is probably the
funniest one i've ever seen in my life
out of all of the world
uh
yeah
i'm finding it right now i got it
um
here it is
this is one of the out of all of the
alex running community son of a [ __ ]
videos it's i put it in show links that
is
that is the choice one that one always
come on over here come on over here
come on you're not in the high school
that was always my favorite one because
it even lines the music up oh [ __ ]
he goes through and it immediately does
the loading
i used to man i love alex
ah you're awake you're a fake and a
phony come here son of a [ __ ]
just immediately touch the [ __ ]
loading screen
that would just make oblivion so much
more lit